[Musique]
donc Evelyne Robert
on a 44 ans mais habite au boiscourt à
la Plaine des cars
depuis 2004 et puis le président de la
commission des agricultrices au sein de
la FDSEA depuis peu près deux ans
j'étais un parcours très très difficile
parce que moi ce que m'a rencontré
principalement sur mon exploitation
c'est surtout des problèmes fonciers et
le coup de main comme elle a eu c'est de
parler bien sûr c'est un syndicat
agricole qui défend les agriculteurs les
agricultrices et donc voilà était élue à
ce moment-là président de la commission
agricultrice c'est comme il dit toujours
nous les jamais par hasard à un endroit
mon expérience
va apporter aux autres dames qui peut
qui peut rencontrer ces mêmes
difficultés pas accompagner azote bien
écoute bah fais comme ça on fait comme
si en tant que femme nous donne
un produit de qualité les animaux landir
tout le long de l'année et midi
versifier aussi un petit peu sur
l'exploitation avec du maraîchage sur
l'exploitation d'un Mika de le fumier de
mes animaux me dis pas que mes faits de
l'agriculture biologique mais il fait de
la culture raisonnée
[Musique]
oui pourraient qualifier à moi de
personnes courageuses et
persévérante dans ce que fait si m'en
avait pas de courage pour arriver
jusqu'au milieu aujourd'hui malgré la
vie et persévérante parce que dans la
vie si il dit que vient peut-être demain
à tout autre vidéo parce que peut-être
bien que si moi avec continuer peut-être
bien que non moi si mes points cap et
que mon ami pense que ce que me défend
les légitime mais ça va je
[Musique]
sauvegarder justement l'été pour que
nous puissent travailler et surtout
mettre à disposition les terres que les
gens ils savent pas sauver ce que nous
emmène dans les assiettes réunionnaises
ça dit il faut que les politiques et m'y
connais que le département ils
travaillent beaucoup là-dessus c'est
promouvoir le produit local si il nous
arrive à faire ça et ben l'agriculture
réunionnaise elle n'y pense que
[Musique]
alors tes chérema
agricultrice élu à la Chambre
d'Agriculture et présidente association
féminine pour le développement agricole
de la Réunion
[Musique]
agricultrice déjà c'est mon mari la
commencé et m'a fait grandir mes enfants
et puis quand les enfants la rentrent à
l'école m'a décidé de être mon mari ce
que les compliquer dans mon métier
d'agricultrice c'est que les
agriculteurs ils croient que nous n'avez
pas capable de
par exemple prendre la pioche et
ralentio
agriculteurs il est vraiment dur quoi et
puis les normal aussi un critères c'est
pas un métier facile on est obligé de
faire nos preuves oui il faut encore
changer les mentalités
l'association féminine pour le
développement agricole de la Réunion
parce que les femmes dans l'agriculture
les vrais que les pas trop reconnus
c'est une équipe de jeunes nous voient
plein de choses pour l'avenir la vente
de produits
nous aussi parce que nous ne peut pas
parler que de l'agriculture aussi on
connaît de femme qui parle pas que de
l'agriculture pour changer un peu les
idées aussi alors nous fait un travail
de conseil aussi auprès des agriculteurs
là par exemple nous la Cécile house nous
l'a trouvé 6 agricultrices qui vous
rendent dans l'association pour nous
cette découverte parce que nous connaît
pas du tout la production et plus elle
va apprendre aussi les gens de la Plaine
des cafés
des caves ils agricultrissent du
quotidien Joseph il fait de curcuma il
fait de la roue tout ça nous ne connaît
pas donc c'est pour ça on a beaucoup
d'échanges dans l'association
l'association émet en place là leur
train de mettre en place des marchés de
productrices pour prouver que
produits c'est nous qui fait nous
participons à faire tout ça
alors solidarité parce que il faut
donner aux agriculteurs les informations
si dans ma façon aussi
oui
bien pas avoir les gens dans le mauvaise
situation donc si le Gateway une
solution puzzle mais c'est
que tout le monde travaille ensemble
parce que c'est les agriculteurs
travaillent mais il faut la population
ils consomment ce que nous fait aussi
m'encourager à nous de travailler bon
allez dit que le produit local est chez
elle est pas cher et puis c'est pour la
santé aussi parce que tout ce qui sort
dehors il y a plein de produits dessus
les gens ils nous réalisent mal mais
trouver la Réunion malheureusement nous
l'entraîne une pièce de notre tradition
[Musique]
alors ces maillot Edwina donc en
activité principale c'est fleuriste et
manel a une double activité c'est
agricultrice avec mon mari sur silhouse
manena ma petite boutique alors je fais
des métiers d'art et au niveau de
l'agriculture donc diversifier aussi
donc maraîchage lentilles et
transformation de produits pour le
magasin
[Musique]
il y a aussi la lentille qu'on va
bientôt commencer à planter au mois de
mai on a là sur les terrains on a le
chien donc les graines de chia
on a fait un petit peu d'ail diversifié
en fait sur les terrains pour
l'agriculture
[Musique]
de formation pour la FSTA donc syndicat
des agriculteurs donc il fait de la
formation florale moi fleurissent c'est
pas que que piquer des fleurs dans dans
de la mousse tout simplement c'est aussi
la créativité
récupération de matériaux
en fait c'est un moment de partage et
que nous crée ensemble des choses à la
demande et me fait partie aussi des
membres de bureau de la PSC
l'association planteur de l'anti-dessus
il est pas moins apportent des
subventions pour le développement de la
lentille sur Cilaos sans fond dans une
association les difficiles de faire que
les expériences et les pour les avenir
en fait donc là il donne à nous les
subventions c'est pour expérimenter
d'autres façons de cultiver et de pas
utiliser tout ce qui est pesticides dans
l'avenir
[Musique]
j'ai épousé mon mari en 1900 et 59 il
était domestique la maison des Villaines
son grand-père l'été installés
en Inde les gens qui ramassent les
enfants et les personnes là-bas pour
amener des engagistes ici à la Réunion
ils ont parlé ils ont demandé ils
avaient où il fait quoi allons amène
nous voir quelque chose quelque part
quand il a vu quand Nathalie dans bateau
pour rendre la Réunion là il a dit que
les trois perdus il y avait plein de
parents et là il y a compris
il a pas demandé pour venir travailler
il était triste ma maman tout le temps
il me parlait de son grand-père son papa
il était triste tout le temps il a
travaillé à l'usine de Vilaine il avait
12 ans on a travaillé beaucoup
à l'usine petit à le fil dedans ce fil
là on fait et la corde pour les bateaux
et là dans la vie des femmes et des
hommes qui travaillaient là-dedans
toutes les colons des cultivent s'y
attaque terrain même mon mari aussi il a
fait ça l'obliger donner quatre journées
à Monsieur devilel point nettoyez ce
canal pour mettre propre ou à le sol
bassin des aigrettes monter à monacader
mais toutes ces que tu plantes tu as le
terrain de Vilaine un quart pour des
vilaine trois quatre le propriétaire qui
plante mais comme les femmes engagées
non plus ma maman il appartient avec son
président enfant tu es solidaire avec
mon frère monsieur et ma maman était une
belle femme indienne elle était très
intelligente elle était charritable elle
a aidé beaucoup désengagé il était à
recy-marché l'avait pu manger et j'étais
petit renvoyant m'apporter de lait porte
de l'eau va regarder ces gens là
travailler très dur si tu rigoles tu
manges si tu rigoles pas tu manges pas
il y en a quelqu'un qui a passé
manger dans la bouche combien pèse
combien d'enfants devant moi
et son mari connait me dire jamais il me
fait pas ça mais là tout le terrain
Simon non mais la moto obligé engager le
terrain fait des stages
à la 60 ans et j'ai perdu mon mari à 64
ans j'étais rejeté de la voiture tout le
monde a pensé je vais décédé ou bien je
dois être handicapé ben du coup comment
dire que voilà il m'a senti m'a fait des
livres de Marie curieux de mon histoire
mon bonheur mon héritage c'est mon
enfant et là j'ai un petit enfant il est
parti travailler université en Inde
c'est mon bonheur il a retrouvé
c'est super
productrice de goyavier sur la planète
des palmiste et fière de l'être je suis
née en métropole mes parents sont
rayonnés j'ai vécu à Poissy tout au long
jusqu'à l'âge de mes 12 ans et à 12 ans
je me suis retrouvée à la place des
palmistes s'il y a eu un choc de culture
entre les deux et du coup une petite
avril avec qui arrive habillé en jean
c'était pas trop à la boîte quoi c'est
pas comme aujourd'hui et j'ai commencé à
vraiment être vraiment faire partie de
la plaine c'est quand mes copines se
sont avérées mes cousines donc voilà
c'est la fille d'athèle voilà voilà
que j'ai été intégrée on va dire je fais
partie de des palmiers quelques années
plus tard mon père tombe malade et là il
commence à parler de louer ou avant ou
enfin voilà voilà ça a été ça a été le
on va dire un choc intérieur je dirais
et je lui ai dit c'est hors de question
c'est tous ces moments assez difficiles
pour qu'aujourd'hui que bien à quelqu'un
d'autre donc c'est là que j'ai décidé de
faire mon diplôme agricole dire mon
métier de base c'est coiffeuse en
faisant mon diplôme agricole ça a été le
la révélation et c'est là où je me suis
sentie dans mon élément pourquoi je me
suis revendiquée productrice de goyave
tout simplement parce que ça n'existait
pas cette filière et je me disais bah on
doit exister sur un papier et je me suis
rendu compte qu'on n'existait pas puis
on n'existait pas mais c'était surtout
pour valoriser le fruit et la culture de
goyavier je veux dire elle existe depuis
pas depuis 10 ans on y va attendre
depuis qu'elle est mis en avant elle
existe depuis plus de 100 ans je veux
dire donc là il y a eu le la création
d'une association qui aujourd'hui
s'appelle les producteurs nutriavier ben
nous on voulait vraiment être une force
et puis aussi pour dire comme ça tu es
ben on travaille quoi je veux dire c'est
très facile de dire que c'est une peste
végétale si elle est pas maîtrisée oui
il y a des gens qui depuis des décennies
c'était leur gagne pas aujourd'hui on
est une vingtaine de vergers sur la
planète organisée on s'est battu pendant
des années pour se faire reconnaître
pour démontrer que en fait quand on
était légitime quoi depuis 2017 on a on
est devenu un GIE un pari fou un
groupement d'intérêt économique
environnemental c'était quasi impossible
et ben non on l'a fait vous savez quand
il y a les gens qui viennent les
touristes tout ça qui découvrent c'est
quoi Gwen pourquoi c'est pas en
métropole ça il faut venir c'est la
Réunion et surtout la planète palmistes
c'est exclusif et aujourd'hui quand je
vois dans les yeux mes parents il a pas
besoin de parler ça c'est comme si vous
portez leur voix et je pense que j'étais
destiné à ça je pense je